[Music]
i'll probably erase this okay here we go
all right guys i gotta focus during the
game so i won't really be answering too
many questions
so draw i don't have any i don't have
any rook lifts down
um
yeah i'm really tied down here
let's let's do a magnus style exchange
stack
should have made a night
oh my god
i'm gonna lose on time though all right
yes pre-moving is good
he's gonna sack a piece that's a good
move
very practical play
oh yeah and he's gonna win probably
wait how does he wet perpetual
it's not over
ah i should have knocked my king over
why would i pre-move that
just walk my king over
i'm just dumb can you see seven can be
six
can maybe escape
what's up pj
wow what is he sitting there for
oh god i've wanted a piece here
very bad
notice it back
and now i'm going to or keyblenders i
don't know what's going on
wow that was bad
okay
oh my god oh okay okay this is good
my knight on h5 was defending there
i gotta go king g7
and now trade queens and this should be
winning
okay
let's start attacking defend
attack okay question g4 okay let's go to
g1
very superficial move okay here
now we want to swing the knight around
to e3 i feel like i've done nothing
except move my knight in this game
don't i have this though little tactic
okay can i get away with this
i think i can yeah i definitely can
now can i get away with this and then
this and then this
lobster pincer
he's gonna go bishop b6 or something
let's just freaking cancel
hmm complicated i'm winning a piece here
that's mate
it's like a petrov on steroids
you can go here
go here
i don't like this
maybe i can simply simplify this place
you from
you can go here and then pre-movement d5
that was a risky premium but it was a
good one
now let's start attacking him
i can try to flag him here
he lost on time
okay
96 probably winner 40's got 23.
oh this is very strong
okay but i actually win this one it's
not so bad
this is a win okay
unlike some of you i don't really care
about the rating so i won't stop here
i slept like six hours i don't know what
you guys talking about
i don't like this position
i'm going to try to sack the bishop and
push the pawns
okay whatever
i should have played a little faster
though but i was trying to save my pawns
i could try this fine i was completely
lost when i lost the piece
okay let's go for activity i am down a
couple pawns here
and this is probably going to be lost
but we'll see
this is a nice game by elerasa
okay too slow too slow
i already had this
whoa that's a free queen
just don't want to give them any chances
here
all right
okay we're supposed to give the bishop
here
okay now i'm trying to clamp down on
these weak squares that he's got
let's go here
okay okay
let's go to rook takes let's take it
yeah losing this one
all right
no i've had this mouse i mean it is a
new mouse but i've had it for like two
months is the g pro super light
it's the new logitech it's really good i
can recommend it
okay
you do that
i'm just getting lucky most games i mean
just
just what it is and this will probably
turn around
alright oh my god he mouse lift and i
didn't do anything but
it's still good yeah he resigns
hi evelyn it's not over i can take his
queen
in most cases or take his pawn around
there
hard for him to untangle here it's
interesting
okay this is interesting yeah but
probably he's got too many pawns here
let's see
yeah i've got too little too coupons
again
this is bad
thank you for the three bucks
oh my god no i'm starting to play badly
okay i'm blundering pieces every move
now
okay now i have this
let's go for activity yeah
now i'm playing badly
this one's in the can
okay now we gotta reset the win streak
here
yeah okay this just was e4 with a
horrible end game
and i blended the pawn back
i'll just slow it down a little bit
yeah but i thought i'm better here
there's your five
or maybe it's equal there's a little
yeah there was no no shot there to win
played very accurately
this one i should be able to win
of course this is not a good move
there was that
i can't defend the pawn
god
[Applause]
oh my god
man
should be winning
all right all right
okay don't let him catch up i mean i
appreciate the support but
i'm doing my best here he's good he's
playing better than he was at the start
he was really tilted at the start so
okay if he takes a tank though yeah
big whoop
he's gonna go rook a3 at some point
obviously he's gonna take the pawn or
something
the key is to not pre-move
this is the one
alexandra and i alexander and i need to
work a little bit on
her ability to mate in these positions
and her ability to flag in these
positions that's one of the things we'll
do during the drill
oh
it's one of the crucial skills in bullet
is this ability to like flag people into
a versus rock positions and stuff like
that
oh he's got this freaking move
it's a horrible game
goodbye you
there's more calculation than people
realize i mean you do calculate some
lines
you you try to calculate minimally but
you do calculate that there's
no doubt about it it's not just you are
just moving the math really fast
if it was then the video gamers would be
fast would be the fastest 30 seconds
left it was just about mass movement
and ali-raz i'm sure would agree with me
but don't i have this if he takes eggs
when he one king aged two queen e5
q1 g5 g3 king queen b2 kg1
queen c1 f1 wins see i wasn't
calculating
oh god okay let's sack the knife
why did i do that it's so stupid
stupid that's very stupid stupid stupid
stupid okay let's take here
it's very stupid this is america and
they cannot play bullets i'm making
stopped okay queen is actually trapped
yeah goodbye that was once i lost the
night it was over
i'm playing dirty i'm playing
i'm i haven't done a single dirty thing
how am i playing dirty i don't believe
you said that
i mean people like to i'll res is my boy
he wouldn't say
that also take it as a compliment
okay if he wants this flag the living
daylights out of him here
at least i'm going to try or he's going
to just
outplay me in a down down obstacle
bishop end game
yes he is okay but i can go here
i can win one of his problems
no it's probably losing actually
where is it what if i go king off
that was dirty now that was dirty i i
confess i confess
that was a dirty move the echo thank you
but that's what you got to do in 30
second chess
i was not like this before oh he is
saying it
but but this is we've always done this
i'm actually playing more
cleanly than i used to i don't know what
he's on about
i'm actually trying to play proper chess
here
for the most part
there's a little stuff you pull in 30
second chest that's normal
i don't know i don't buy it
100 best things
another one in the can
there's an accident
yeah he's going to win the spawn in the
game thank you man
gifting blackstone
let's see if i can flag him
yeah too much do a little time
oh my god oh bishop basics yeah i didn't
expect particular fun
should be pretty crushing
that was i wonder what the accuracy was
i think other than bishop basics that
was a good game
i think i played a legitimately good
game there
yeah what's knight f5
is it changed first well i've gotten
older i'm older
i'm wiser well none the wiser i guess
but i'm younger at heart
i don't know in what context he means
these words
you cannot pass on me it's not stalemate
i forced him to on persona then it's me
that's why i won that
okay i've got a good night but that's
about all i've got
okay it's gonna make me careful
it's basically made so i've got i've got
a sack tonight and
try to seek some counter play with my
pawns still got some play
but no just got too much material
okay
here
that's right brandon that was a good
game
okay what is he sitting there for
trying to put the pressure on him
thank you manto tur himself something
all right i couldn't move queen e5 the
one move to flag me
unbelievable
then it happens
thank you
i was that dirty i just needed him
yeah i don't see it
hmm
okay let's allow queen f7
benoni is good in 30 sec
okay let's simplify the position
lexus
it's a free exchange
it's not entirely over though oh my god
now it is
very poor
um
yeah he didn't pre-move i thought he
might pretty much
yeah i'm gonna get made it here i gotta
open the center
oh my god i'm walking into these easy
tactics
just elementary tactics
again
i gotta win a couple here
let's go right here
he plays this better in thirty second
than some people i know in classical
i'm going to loose up a full piece
unbelievable
what's going on here 16
okay i don't see it i'm just taking a
win
yeah this line
oh my god i should have gotten queen b7
i should have anticipated it
very bad
gotta win a couple here just to extend
the lead again
he's playing like a machine these couple
couple games here
whether the storm
okay now i gotta win this next one is
very important
very important game here somehow
just to get back on like a good good run
okay the next one is also very important
get them to get them tilted again
super important
you
of course i lose
yeah i managed to lose that one
my magic
yeah he is the best supreme over in
history i mean
i can compete but like he might be the
fastest player to ever walk the earth
like his combination of strength and
strength and
and accuracy is unmatched
he's gonna lose on time he's gonna flag
well well he's drunk
that was a miracle safe
he's not happy about that one
come on what am i doing
yes got him there again